Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David P.. You know,
I wonder. Do the does my audience call other
shows to complain about me because so many of our
callers call me to complain about other people?
The San Antonio troll regularly complains to me
about things I didn't say that he heard on other
shows. Troy York regularly calls in to complain
about other people, and that's what he did,
unleashing a brutal and completely unintelligible
attack on Kyle Koplinski of secular talk. I don't
know what Troy's talking about, and I don't know
why he's calling me about Kyle. See if you can
make any heads or tails out of this or figure out
how this even has anything to do with me.
Speaker 4: David Kyle Polansky is a propagandist
and a liar who keeps attacking companies
that are resisting unionization and Starbucks
and Amazon. Two examples OK. Are companies that
would not exist through massive unionization, and
this is the goal of Kyle Kaminski. He wants to
see Starbucks destroyed more empty storefronts
in communities across this country.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, quite frankly,
I haven't been to Starbucks in 20 years. I quite
frankly think the coffee is a disaster. So I'm
half kidding. I understand the jobs
component, but I'm no big Starbucks
fan. Maybe Kyle shares in that? I don't know.
Speaker 4: He attacked Amazon despite the
great services and products that it's able to
deliver. OK. And Kyle Kaminsky is basically
a undemocratic, ignorant socialist,
Speaker 1: a undemocratic, ignorant socialist.
Speaker 4: And I don't know how you ignorant
leftist by Kyle Cohen's scheme where you continue
to lie and propagandize on the internet? Hmm.
Speaker 1: How can I guess the
same way Troy does? I don't know.
Speaker 4: Like yourself and Jane Cogan
and Sam Theater
Speaker 1: also what's playing
in the background, but it's like my show is
always playing in the background of these calls.
Speaker 4: Hate this country are anti-American.
You say nothing about no one, not one of this
unionization attempts against Starbucks
and Amazon, and we've ever complained about
the workers in Kerkorian's. They are mostly funded
by drug cartels in Mexico. Immigrant business. You
never talk about immigrant business and Indian
restaurants being unionization. Yeah, I mean,
Speaker 1: I don't know what Troy York is talking
about, and I don't know why he's calling me about
Kyle Koplinski, and I don't know what Kyle
said. But please call Kyle. I mean, is it
why? Why do you have to call me? Just call Kyle.
Tell him what you think. And I don't know, man,
it's it's very, very strange to call me. We're
going to have a great bonus show for you today.
We knew that vehicle fatalities were up
during the pandemic, but we didn't know why.
We now know that excessive speed due to less busy
roads played a role in that. We are going to talk
about wind and solar, which now are responsible
for 10 percent of global energy production. That's
still not a massive number, but it's a big change
and things are going in the right direction there.
We are also going to talk about another
one of the problems that has to be dealt
with for long term space travel for humans.
You know, in the past, we've talked about
the radiation component needs to be figured out.
A lot of radiation when you travel through space.
The other issue is bone loss, and there's a new
study about it. I want to talk a little bit about
cycling and some things that are connected between
those things and a lot of energy now going into
how do we deal with the bone loss issue?
And that's something that's already being
studied. Very, very interesting stuff and eclectic
bonus show for you today. You can sign up and get
instant access at joint Packman dot com. The
coupon code Wow twenty two will save you a bundle.
And I really look forward to seeing
you on the bonus show. Last reminder
for today. I'll remind you again next Tuesday,
April 19th, we will be doing a live viewer town
hall at 6:00 PM Eastern Time. It will be open
to everybody. Members will have their own way
of getting in touch with me during the town hall.
And it's going to be streaming only on our second
YouTube channel, the Pacman Live YouTube channel.
So make sure you're subscribed there. It's free.
It's free to subscribe. It's free to
watch. It's everybody can call in.
But if you want priority handling during
the town hall, become a member at Join PAC
McConnell. See everybody on the bonus
show. And then back here tomorrow.